We did the most-
I'm so glad
that you'd have me.
Fun movie together, "Boys On The Side".
And we just, we were young.
We had fun.
We were really authentic friends.
We were, we had a great time,
And there wasn't a ton of girl movies back then,
No.
Celebrating female friendship.
You did "Fried Green Tomatoes",
which we're-
That's true.
You're gonna teach us to cook.
That was the epitome,
(audience applauds)
of female friendship.
But that movie was perfect for you
because you were such a woman's woman and a girl.
And I always felt like you want everyone to win.
I do.
Especially the females.
I feel like you are always rooting for everybody,
which some people put that on
and you can tell that behind that,
is another face going on,
but you really mean it
and I love that about you.
And I loved that I got to be truly who I was
and like you and Whoopi, we were just us.
We were ourselves and we loved and embraced
and had the best time.
I mean, we worked hard.
We did.
It was, Herb Ross, our director.
Herb, yeah, he loved you, so much.
Matthew McConaughey,
one of his big breakouts.
Was this one of his first?
Yeah.
And he would walk around the halls talking to himself.
Do you remember that?
A lot of bongos.
He'd be like, "Get it together McConaughey."
(audience laughs)
Yeah, it's really.
He would talk to himself.
And he, oh my God, he played Abe Lincoln.
The policeman.
I know.
Oh my God.
I remember that.
And Herbert Ross, our director,
was like "I discovered the next big star."
And we were like, "Yeah".
Okay, wow.
You see that?
Yeah.
Like he was meg, oh, he's so dynamic.
All right.
So, speaking of female friendship,
working together,
food, love and all things wonderful.
Teach us how to make your beautiful popovers.
So they're really simple
and they're so celebratory and so beautiful.
They're so gorgeous.
They make people really happy.
So the number one thing to remember is
that things should be at room temperature.
The eggs should be at room temperature.
The milk should be at room temperature.
You can warm it if you want, and this should be preheated.
So as you're making the batter
this, we'll pretend like, ah, ah, it's hot, but it's not.
So you'd put this in the oven at 450.
This is a very unique,
this is not your cupcake tin.
No, this is a popover tin.
And you'd put a pad of butter in each one,
so the butter browns.
So this is just room temp, eggs, room temp milk.
And you mix it in with the flour,
and it can be lumpy.
Should I go for it?
The batter can be a little bit lumpy.
Mm-hm, yeah, just go for it.
And you also have a little bit of melted butter
and a little bit of vanilla.
Mother...
This thing, I can't believe it's still here.
Everybody, I, every single time, look at this.
Why do you have several spouts?
Look how stupid this is.
Also your cookware back there.
Thank you.
Gorgeous.
This is not our line.
I'm not I'm.
This is, we would not make this.
Mm-mm.
(audience laughs)
I'm already messy,
but this does me no favors, okay.
So you can add a little pinch of salt
but it's not really...
I like salt because I like it
when it has is a savory kick somewhere in there.
So do I do the whole thing or just a pinch?
No just like another pinch.
I don't really use recipes that much but you're gonna add
a little vanilla.
You're more
of an eye-baller, vanilla?
A little bit of melted butter.
Butter!
Oh, do you remember, you used to imitate Fabio?
Oh my God!
Yeah.
Yes.
She used to walk around saying...
"I can't believe it's not butter."
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Made me laugh every time.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
How hilarious.
Why do I remember that?
Amazing.
So this is what they're gonna be in the end,
rolled in the cinnamon sugar
and mixed with either maple cream cheese or maple butter.
Should I fill these?
Mm-hm.
Okay.
So fill them about three quarters full.
That was gonna be my next question.
Yeah.
Perfect, perfection.
Oh God, I'm so uptight in my stomach right now.
Just so you know.
I don't have that sexy, whimsical thing in the kitchen.
So do these go into the-
Oven, let me...
I always love this on TV,
when they put it in.
I know, the magic of TV.
Isn't it fun?
And then, here.
So, this is the magic.
Will you open the oven for me?
Will I, are you kidding?
Mm-hm.
This is the, this one?
Yeah.
Perfect.
I'll stick it in.
I love a popover tin.
Mm-hm.
Shall we...?
Magic.
(audience applauds)
Oh, look!
Magic.
Tada!
And look!
(audience applauds and cheers)
(gasps) Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
No, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
You missed me.
All good, all good.
Okay,
and then now that the popovers are done.
Browned butter
Browned butter, roll it.
Roll it in the browned butter.
I'll roll in the browned butter.
Roll it in the butter.
No problem whatsoever.
Rolling in brown butter.
No, everything's better with butter.
So now cream, cheese or butter.
Do you think?
"I can't believe."
(audience laughs)
Which would you prefer?
How about the maple butter?
Sure.
This is maple butter.
So it has maple butter.
It's butter mixed with maple syrup.
And then you put the maple butter inside.
Okay, so here we go.
Oh my God.
Cheers.
(audience applauds)
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
(audience cheers and applauds)
That's good, huh?
So good.
So delicious.
I know, right?
I'm not kidding, I will never,
ever forgot eating this.
Mm, it's so good, right?
I'm gonna make it now with my girls.
Oh, and they're gonna be, yeah.
And then they'll,
they're tanked for like an hour afterwards.
They're like super happy
and then they're like, (mimics exhausted groan)
Yep, yep, yep.
That's fine.
It's worth it.
#Worth it.
So worth it.
(bright theme music)